what dude
this spacecraft is embarking on an
eight-year journey to study Jupiter and
three of its largest moons the Jupiter
icy moons Explorer also known as juice
is on a mission to characterize what
makes a world habitable so it can
sustain life in our solar system are we
really so special in the cosmos that
Earth is the only place that can support
life forms here's a look at what juice
will explore once it arrives at its
destination and what it might reveal
about the search for life in outer space
[Music]
the juice mission is led by the European
Space Agency partnering with other space
agencies across the world including
those in the U.S Japan and Israel on
board the spacecraft carries a suite of
10 scientific instruments making it the
most powerful payload flown to the outer
solar system
those instruments include a camera
system they include a radar system that
can penetrate several miles into the
surface they're bringing a laser
altimeter which will sort of help them
create a 3D map any spacecraft headed
into outer space will face challenges
from navigating the asteroid belt to a
long roundabout Journey but juice was
designed to withstand some of the
universe's extremes including radiation
and harsh temperatures on its Journey
Juice will encounter nearly 500 degree
temperatures around Venus and close to
minus 400 degree temperatures near
Jupiter when they build these
instruments they not only need to ensure
that they can deliver on the science
that's proposed like they're sensitive
enough and calibrated enough to identify
differences in magnetic fields and
things but also need to survive the
journey right you can't send the plumber
to go fix the instruments juice which
weighs about 10 tons must first complete
flybys of Earth the moon and Venus so it
can adjust its trajectory and gain
enough speed it was challenging to
design the spacecraft because it has to
take such a sort of long journey to get
to Jupiter by the time juice reaches its
destination in July of 2031 the
spacecraft will have traveled nearly 4
billion miles
sitting nearly 450 Million Miles Away
From Earth Jupiter is the largest planet
in our solar system more than twice as
massive as all the other planets
combined one of the NASA scientists
described Jupiter's planetary
neighborhood as sort of like the
Disneyland Universal and Six Flags of
the solar system all rolled into one the
planet is mostly composed of gases like
hydrogen and helium and has a powerful
magnetic field that affects thousands of
objects in its orbit juice will in part
study this atmosphere to understand how
the harsh environment shapes the
conditions on its surrounding moons
among nearly 100 moons orbiting Jupiter
three of the largest Europa Ganymede and
Callisto are all thought to possibly
Harbor oceans of liquid water beneath
their icy crusts after previous missions
shed light on What Lies Beneath the
surface Juice's radar instrument will
sort of help scientists peer under the
surface it might help them understand
how thick the ice is above what is
potentially a subsurface ocean it might
also help reveal whether or not this
ocean is salty scientists will look for
liquid water a heat source and organic
materials on these moons which are among
the ingredients needed to sustain life
it's likely going to be microbes we're
not looking at aliens living under the
ocean surface it could also be maybe
more advanced species sort of similar to
what we might find near deep sea vents
in our own oceans on Earth while juice
can't detect life the mission is a step
toward identifying whether these
ingredients Exist Elsewhere in our solar
system
[Music]
the juice mission is expected to collect
about four years of data before ending
in 2035 but it's not the only spacecraft
observing Jupiter and its surrounding
moons
NASA is also sending a mission to Europa
next year named Europa Clipper that
mission will arrive in 2030 and will
observe the moon at the same time as
juice space science has matured over the
past couple of decades and really honed
in on Jupiter and to look for those
other life forms and juice is a key
requisite to really making that
objective a reality there's no promise
that will detect life on these moons but
if we don't look and see whether or not
they're potentially habitable we won't
actually ever get the answer
[Music]